Before starting with Qatar's clinic, I went to a naturopath. Should I continue?
Well, you can. So, you know, understand, you know, I have always said, you know, I want you to do
what you feel like God is leading you to do. We have lots of people that are talking, they're going
to a car pastor or going to a naturopath or going to a nutritionist and getting advice as well,
and sometimes it's really good to have somebody local that you can talk to and that makes you feel good
and there's all sorts of benefits to that. And if you see a benefit to that then by all means
you don't go with that. But please, at least you don't have to take my opinion, you don't have to agree
with me, you don't have to do anything I tell you to do. But this kind of question like this one
back here, my college and powder has methylated multivitamins, should I discontinue? These are the
kind of questions I need you to ask or I want you to ask because I, you know, there's lots of times
where a person will have a question where they're taking things that I would have never recommended.
Now, you might get a totally different argument from your naturopath and no, I want you to take that.
You need methylated multivitamins. I'm, you know, sometimes people think I give too long of
answers. I had somebody to the day that was unhappy with me because I explained things to them
on the call too long. And I get it, I'm sorry, that's just the way I am, that's why I try to
to give you education so that you are not just following somebody. But you're educated
so you're making your own conscious decisions because now you know something that you didn't know
before. So that's why I try to tell you about just against methylated multivitamins. There's a reason
why a cancer patient wouldn't want to be taking methylated multivitamins. So I'm trying to give you
that data so you can arm yourself. Now, there's a lot of practitioners that don't understand that.
There's probably, there's tons of stuff I don't understand and I learn every day. But when we're
open to learning, then we grow and we're better for it, I believe. So I'm not going to apologize for
over teaching. So go ahead and go to your naturopath if you want to. They could have wonderful benefits for
a lot of different things. But if they do recommend supplements that you have any questions about
just ask, that's what these zoom calls are for, just ask. And I may say, sure, there's no harm in
taking that. Or I may say, I don't think you should take that. And then you could make that decision.
You don't have to do what I tell you to, but I'll give you my honest opinion. So absolutely,
you can continue to take it. I had somebody on the phone the other day that said, I really want to
find an herbalist. What do you want to find an herbalist for? Because I need to know what supplements to
take. This is in a case here. I said, well, that's what I am. Oh, they were pleasantly surprised.
Okay. Well, you know, ask me questions. If I don't know something, you know me well enough,
and I'll say, I don't know. I don't know that answer. I'm not familiar with that. But if I do know
something, I'll give you my opinion. And sometimes I need to correct that opinion because I was wrong.
But let's just learn together. So I want you guys to be educated, make educated decisions so that you're
you could help other people and not just follow someone.